t
convertir leur système
de chauffage, mais
les installateurs ne fournissent
pas à la demande.
Kim Vermette.
NORMAND BRODEUR,
propriétaire d'un duplex
- J'ai fait le saut!
- Normand brodeur chauffe
sa maison au mazout depuis plus
de 20 ans, mais ses factures ont
tout simplement explosé depuis
le début de l'année.
- Ça a été une augmentation
de 88 sous en l'espace
de deux mois, donc,
une augmentation de 78 %.
ce qui l'a poussé
à convertir son système
de chauffage vers l'électricité.
- C'était pas dans mon plan,
puis j'ai pris une décision
rapidement. Quand j'ai vu
la dernière facture, j'ai réagi.
FRANÇOIS LALONDE, fondateur
ÉcoConversions
- On peut la démanteler
en morceaux, et unelle
est démantelée, on peut
l'enlever des lieux.
- François Lalonde s'est
spécialisé dans la conversion
des systèmes de chauffage.
Il est débordé.
- Depuis le mois de janvier,
s'est amplifiée à cause de
la montée assez prononcée
des prix de mazout.
- Mais la demande était déjà là,
surtout depuis que Québec a
annoncé son intention d'éliminer
ces systèmes de chauffage.
Dès 2024, leur installation ou
leur remseront
interdits.
- On prévoit d'ici une dizaine
d'années que les systèmes de
chauffage au mazout pour devenir
quelque chose du passé
au Québec. On peut comme
le charbon dans les années 50,
ça a pris une décennie
pour s'effriter.
LUC BERTRAND, direc. opérations
Les Huiles Bertrand
- C'est sûr que le marché
rapetisse. Depuis que je suis(-,
c'est appelé à disparaître, fait
que... non, ça va rester. C'est
sûr que, là, actuellement, on
vit dans une période que les
lois nous favorisent pas, mais
il va toujours y avoirvoirvoirvr
une certaine demande.
- Le règlement mis en place
par Québec a fait mal
à l'industrie du mazout,
mais Luc Bertrand, quatrième
le milieu, est persuadé que
le prix finira par redescendre.
- Les gens deviennent très
émotifs, souvent,  souvent,  soe
des gestes rapides. Moi, je leur
dis : attendez, d'une manière
Conversion vers un système
électrique coûte 800 millions de
dollars...
- je voulais faire le virageauss
une dépense, c'est un
investissement.
- Québec estime à